hey this is press tow
Walker this video will change how you
view coin tosses forever a Fair coin
shows heads and tails with equal 50%
probability as such it's the age-old
mechanism for deciding things fairly it
was used to decide which right brothers
would fly the first airplane and it's
used in sports to determine who will get
the advantage that might win the match
but just how fair is a coin exactly
imagine you have a coin that shows heads
is it just as likely to show heads when
you flip it the answer is no there's a
slight bias to get exactly the same
side in 2007 a paper by diaconus Holmes
Montgomery suggested the human mechanism
of flipping a coin introduces a
bias to understand it think about hand
tossing a pizza dough if you throw the
dough up and it spins it will land back
on exactly the same side as it
started the same bias can happen when
you toss a
coin when you try to toss a coin and
flip it you introduce a slight wobble in
the spin which makes the coin slightly
more likely to land on the same side as
it started the mathematics and physics
of why this happens are tremendously
complex but in the end they found a
theoretical samide bias of
51% if a Fair coin starts heads it will
end up as heads with a 51% chance if it
starts Tails it will end up tals also
with a 51%
chance but just how accurate is this
theoretical
Model A group of researchers just tested
this out with one of the largest coin
flipping experiments ever in history a
group of 48 people tossed coins of 46
different currencies and denominations
and obtained a total of 350,677
continued in a marathon of coin flipping
in case the coin was not caught in
someone's hand the flip was designated
as a failure and they repeated the
procedure out of all of this they found
a bias of
50.8% to land on the same
side but notice the coins themselves
were not
biased about
175,000 of the
350,000 tosses were heads in other words
the probability of heads was the same as
Tails at about
50% the coins were fair but there was a
samide bias to the flipping of the coins
so what does this all mean for us
practically if you need to bet on a coin
toss make sure you bet on the same side
you'll have an edge to win if you are
the one making the coin toss try to hide
the face that side up so the person
calling it doesn't know this effectively
makes the result
random now you might consider letting
the coin bounce but that can have all
sorts of other biases coins May spin
which introduce a known bias or they may
even land completely on their
Edge you could also consider a simulated
coin toss to avoid the limitations of
physically flipping the coin but no
matter how you slice it the result is
that just flipping a coin is not a fair
mechanism there is a samide bias of
about
51% whether you're the one calling the
coin or making the toss this is an
important distinction we all should
recognize thanks for making us one of
the best communities on YouTube see you
next episode of mind your decisions
where we solve The World's problems one
video at a
time
w